Cordon: Welcome back, to another episode of The Wokking Dead!
Don't you just love a good horror flick?
For every great movie, you've gotta have great popcorn!
Dave: Hey, Cordon! I'm really glad you're coming around to what we talked about earlier.
Cordon: What?
Dave: You know, doing some more consumer friendly recipes.
Cordon: No! No! I don't give a crap about that!
What we're cooking comes from a user named HowBizarre.
He writes:
Dave: Cordon. Think about the consequences of that.
Cordon: Let's make a bet. I bet I can get you to try some by the end of the episode.
Dave: That's not happening.
Cordon: Very well. If you win, I'll make whatever you want, next episode.
But if I win, you have to try a dish of my choosing.
Dave: Fine. Deal. There is literally no way I'm going to try any of that.
Cordon: I'll find a way. Afterall... WE ARE THE WOKKING
DEEEEEADDDDD!!!!
We are the Wokking Dead!
THE WOKKING DEAD!
WE ARE THE WOKKING DEAD!!!!!!
This episode of The Wokking Dead is brought to you by Culinart Productions
putting the craft in craft services.
First thing you'll need is the right kind of popcorn
so we're going to go out into the world and do a bit of shopping.
You'll also need plain popcorn
and it's not like Dave needs the extra calories anyways.
You'll also want syrup,
food coloring,
butter,
sugar,
baking soda,
salt,
and don't forget my favorite: Pure Vanilla Extract...
You'll also need radioactive material, and what better place to get it, than Japan?
Dave: Cordon, you can't leave the country in the middle of a sh--
Japan may be known for it's booming cities and majestic temples,
but it is also home to a wonderful black market.
I enjoyed my time in Japan, but after 3 weeks paid vacation,
I figured it was time to get back and finish the radioactive popcorn.
Dave: Seriously, Cordon, I don't think anybody's going to want to want to eat radioactive popcorn.
I mean, look at this stuff. It looks disgusting.
Cordon: SO DO YOU! But you haven't been yanked off the air yet!
Now preheat the oven to 250°.
And use your saucepan, or as I like to use...
WOK!
And put it on medium heat to melt the butter.
Now, pour in some sugar,
salt,
syrup,
and stir it in there.
Let it boil for four minutes.
Dave: Since we have four minutes, I'd like to talk to you about some regional demographics that we're talk--
Cordon: AUGH, the four minutes is up!
Ah, OK! Remove from the heat,
and add food coloring,
and one shot of vanilla extract.
Ahh!
Yep, there it is.
Alright. I like to take a few extra shots of vanilla.
Don't use that imitation garbage, or else you won't get your daily dose of alcohol in.
That hit the spot!
After you stir in some baking soda,
you can coat the popcorn.
I like to pretend that I'm pouring searing hot oil all over Dave's face.
Dave: I heard that!
OK. Then pop it in the oven for one human hour.
And don't forget to put your radioactive fish on the bottom rack.
Now I have to go before--
Dave: Ugh... Get back here! Cordon...
Oh yeah! Well then I said, "if you want child support, call Dracula!"
Oh, hey. I gotta get back to the show. Later homie!
Ahh! So warm you can feel the radiation poisoning!
The radioactive popcorn is delicious, but I find it's best to just stick one booger in a regular batch of popcorn!
Why don't you give them a try?
Dave: I will not! I told you, I'm not gonna eat this stuff!
Cordon: Would you eat it with some rice?
Dave: No, I will not eat it with rice!
Cordon: Would you eat it with Vincent Price?
Dave: I will NOT eat it with Vincent Price.
Cordon: Would you eat it in the back of a sweaty bus filled with hobos?
Dave: Absolutely not!
Cordon: Toooooo baaaadddd!!!!
Cordon: CZsWorld and Culinart Productions are not responsible if you die from eating this recipe.
So what are you waiting for? Eat it!
Dave: Hey! This is actually pretty good.
Cordon: That's what I was telling you Dave.
Looks like you forgot about our bet.
Now...
Try this!
Ahh!
Dave: Eww... what? What is this?
Cordon: Gooseshit!
Cordon: Thanks for joining us for another episode of The Wokking Dead!
Subscribe for more dangerously good treats.
If you have an idea for a recipe, leave it in the comments!
Remember, try this in your own home, in your own kitchen!
See you next time!